>> Reporter: IN THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY, AISHAH HASNIE, FOX NEWS.
ERIC: A BIPARTISAN GROUP OF
LAWMAKERS ARE NOW LOOKING TO GET
THE BORDER SURGE UNDER CONTROL
WITH A NEW IMMIGRATION BILL.
OUR NEXT GUEST SAYS BORDER
SECURITY IS PARAMOUNT, BUT HE
SAYS IT NEEDS TO BE DONE WITH
IMMIGRATION REFORM THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE CITIZENSHIP BUT DOES
PROVIDE FOR LEGAL STATUS.
HE IS CONGRESSMAN CARLOS
GIMENEZ, HE SITS ON THE HOUSE
HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE.
YOU WERE BORN IN CUBA, WELCOME,
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
FIRST, THE BORDER RIGHT NOW.
YOU VISITED TWICE, YOU’RE GOING
TO GO BACK SOON.
TO YOU, WHAT IS THE SITUATION
LIKE AND WHAT SHOULD BE DONE?
>> IT’S CHAOTIC, AND I KNOW A
LOT OF THINGS BOTHER ME ABOUT
WHAT’S GOING ON.
THE BIDEN/HARRIS POLICIES ARE
ACTUALLY SEPARATING FAMILIES AT
THE BORDER BECAUSE YOUNG KIDS
UNDER 18 YEARS OLD ARE ALLOWED
TO STAY ON THIS SIDE, AND SO
WHAT HAPPENS IS, YOU KNOW,
THAT’S WHY WE’RE SEEING SO MANY
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS CROSSING
THE BORDER, THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF THEM, PUTTING THEM
AT RISK AND DANGER.
THE POLICIES ARE ALSO ENRICHING
THE MULTI-NATIONAL CARTELS TO
THE TUNES OF HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A MONTH.
WE HAVE POLICIES NOW THAT WE’RE
ACTUALLY PAYING OUR CONTRACTORS
ON OUR SIDE TO NOT CONSTRUCT THE
WALL, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS NOT TO CONSTRUCT THE
WALL.
PART OF THAT WALL IS ALSO A
LEVEE SYSTEM THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT OUR ARE RESIDENTS AND
CITIZENS FROM FLOODING, SO
THAT’S NOT BEING DONE.
THERE’S A WHOLE MYRIAD OF STUFF
THAT’S HAPPENING AT THE BORDER
THAT CONCERNS ME AND THE
POLICIES OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
ARE TO BLAME FOR THIS SURGE THAT
WE’RE SEEING AT THE BORDER.
ERIC: YEAH, IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
I GUESS IT MUST BE THE
CONTRACTS, YOU KNOW, YOU
CONTRACTED TO BUILD A WALL, AND
IF YOU STOP IT, YOU’VE STILL GOT
TO PLAY THE MONEY.
THAT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
>> IT IS.
ERIC: HOW DO WE FIX THIS?
>> WELL, I THINK WE NEED TO
REVERT TO SOME OF THE POLICIES
WE HAD IN THE PAST.
HOLDING ASYLUM SEEKERS ON THE
MEXICAN SIDE OF THE BORDER WILL
DISINCENTIVIZE PEOPLE FROM
COMING.
LOOK, IF YOU KNOW THAT YOU CAN
GET TO THE OTHER SIDE, TO OUR
SIDE OF THE RIO GRANDE AND
BASICALLY BE PROCESSED AND THEN
THE RELEASED INTO THE COUNTRY,
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A REALLY GOOD
SHOT AT JUST STAYING HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES WHICH IS YOUR END
GAME.
AND SO THE OLD POLICY OF
PROCESSING THEM AT THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE BORDER REALLY
REDUCED THE LIKELIHOOD THAT YOU
WERE EVER GOING TO MAKE IT OVER
SUCCESSFULLY BY 90%.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE ODDS.
THAT’S WHY YOU HAVE THIS HUGE
SURGE.
AND RESTORING THOSE POLICIES
WITH MEXICO, RESTORING THE
POLICIES AND AGREEMENTS THAT WE
HAD WITH GUATEMALA AND EL
SALVADOR AND HONDURAS, THAT
NEEDS TO BE RESTORED.
AND THEN THE RULE OF LAW.
WE NEED TO ADD ADDITIONAL JUDGES
AT THE BORDER SO WE CAN PROCESS
THESE ASYLUM CASES MUCH QUICKER.
SO THERE’S A WHOLE MYRIAD OF
STUFF THAT WE NEED TO DO, AND
IT’S REALLY COMMON SENSE.
WE NEED TO FOLLOW WHAT THE
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION
AGENTS HAVE SAID.
THEY NEED MORE PEOPLE, THEY NEED
TECHNOLOGY AND THEY NEED
INFRASTRUCTURE, AND THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE’S ACTUALLY
COMPLETING THAT WALL.
WE’VE ALREADY GOT TO SPEND THE
MONEY, WHY DON’T YOU LET THE
CONTRACTORS GO AHEAD AND FINISH
WHAT THEY STARTED SO WE DON’T
WASTE TENS IF NOT HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND PAYING
PEOPLE TO NOT TO DO ANYTHING.
ERIC FINALLY ON THAT POINT, ARE
YOU SURPRISED MOST PEOPLE DON’T
KNOW THAT?
THAT WE’RE PAYING FOR THE WALL
NOT TO BE BUILT?
>> YEAH, I THINK MOST PEOPLE --
I DIDN’T KNOW IT UNTIL WE GOT
THERE, AND OUR CUSTOMS AND
BORDER PROTECTION PEOPLE SAID,
OH, BY THE WAY, SEE ALL THAT
EQUIPMENT AND MATERIAL?
WE’RE PAYING THOSE CONTRACTORS
NOT TO BUILD THE WALL.
TO ME, THAT’S INSANITY.
I MEAN, YOU’RE PAYING NOT TO
BUILD THE WALL?
AND THE CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION AGENTS ARE SAYING WE
NEED THOSE PORTIONS OF THE WALL
TO BE COMPLETED BECAUSE THAT’S A
FORCE MULTIPLIER.
IT ACTUALLY, IN THE END, WILL
SAVE US MONEY.
WE WON’T NEED AS MANY AGENTS TO
GUARD THE BORDER IF WE HAVE THE
WALL, IF WE HAVE TECHNOLOGY, YOU
KNOW?
AND RESTORATION OF SOME OF THESE
POLICIES.
SO, YOU KNOW, TO ME, IT’S
INSANITY.
AND IT’S ALL IDEOLOGICAL.
IT’S GOT NOTHING TO DO WITH
COMMON SENSE OR WHAT’S REALLY
HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
ERIC: WELL, WE’RE PAYING NOT TO
BUILD THE WALL, SAYS CONGRESSMAN
CARLOS JIMENEZ FROM FLORIDA.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU FOR THAT
SURPRISING INSIGHT AND WANT YOU
BACK AFTER YOU HAVE YOUR NEXT